welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and we just got a new trailer for
the falcon and the winter soldier coming
to disney plus march 19th we saw a
little preview during the big game and
then it said full trailer online so you
know what i did i rushed up here to the
blue dungeon and then i went online
boy oh boy there's a full two minutes of
this so i'm gonna react to this
i'm gonna give you my first thoughts on
what this show is gonna be
how it's gonna tie into the madness of
one division right now
and pick up the pieces after avengers
end game and then uh hopefully tomorrow
maybe the next day after that you're
gonna get my full
in-depth shot by shot frame by frame
analysis of all the details you missed
in this trailer but uh for now let's
just watch this and react to it
so here we go
so who would like to start
mr barnes why does sam aggravate you
15 seconds to drop so what's our plan
[Music]
great [ __ ]
look at that mattress [ __ ] cannot be
allowed
to exist
[Music]
i have no intention to leave my work
finished
the wall's upside down right now
oh yeah what is oh here we it
hello girl kick your ass
[Music]
see that wasn't so hard are you ready
just blank sweet jesus i mean how old
are you
all right well how old is bucky let's do
the math here
uh i think his birthday was like he was
a year older than
steve 19 17. he dusted in 2018
he was 101 when he dusted and then he
came back to paint on when this is if
it's in 2024
so he's either 101 102 years old boom we
got it but either way he's
old as [ __ ] that's why he's like you
don't want to know lady
but before i continue online shopping
has basically become the only shopping
these days and that's where today's
sponsor honey comes in honey is the free
browser extension that scours the
internet for coupon codes and
automatically tests them
when you are checking out so here's how
it works so you get honey on your
computer for free in two easy clicks and
then when you are checking out on one
prices drop i saved 10 bucks on an
edible arrangement i sent for
valentine's day because honey found me a
discount code for it and those of you
who might have already installed honey
using my link have found over 483
000 in savings you could be one of those
people now it's simple
if you have a computer honey should be
on it it's free and it works with
whatever browser you use get honey for
free today by going to
joinhoney.com new rockstars that's
joinhoney.com
new rockstars so they know that i sent
you and thanks again to honey for
sponsoring today's video
all right so um some of the imagery some
of the footage that we've seen before
right uh we are introduced to some
characters baron zemo
from captain america civil war is coming
back danny bruhl's character but this
time we see him carrying his
uh comic accurate purple mask uh
and yeah his mission is still kind of
what his mission was in captain america
civil war he's trying to destroy the
avengers uh it didn't really work for
him in civil war
or did it no no they came back in
avengers infinity war they were fine
but uh yeah now that like tony stark is
gone now that cap's an old man retired
probably a lot of the avengers are kind
of scattered retired done moving on
uh and he's finding this opportunity as
the next generation of avengers are
trying to pick up the shield pick up the
mantle
bear the torch uh and he's trying to rid
the world
of them we get another look at aaron
kellerman's character she is playing
uh well i thought she was playing a
version of songbird for now she's being
called
part of a group called the flag smashers
now in the comics flagsmaster is just
like one guy he's a captain america
villain he's also a villain to like um
moon knight and ghost rider punisher he
leads a group called
ultimatum which is another acronym and
their whole mission is to unite mankind
by
ridding them of their flags of their
identities but in this case flag smasher
might be doing that by
trying to turn these avengers against
the
patriotic iconography that no longer
really cares about them
because as we know john walker us agent
is kind of the government's poster boy
for who's gonna be the successor of
captain america there's a shot here
where
bucky's kind of pissed off as he's
watching someone else get uh awarded
with uh military badges
but really this whole trailer seems to
be like hey marvel fans don't worry we
have more
avengers-y action-packed stuff coming
your way it's not just like
mystery x-files one division confusion
and yeah
i'm super pumped to see this sharon
carter is confirmed to come back
she's beating people with pipes we also
know this series is going to explore
some parts of the mcu globe that are
just fictional but kind of like wakanda
do exist in this world so
for example we're going back to sokovia
we see baron zemo standing at this
sokovian memorial there's that big pond
behind it that looks like that could
have been part of the runoff water from
when that city was yanked out of the
earth and dropped back down
this makes it two shows it looks like
that's returning to the drama of
what happened in age of ultron but we're
also expanding to a new place we've
never seen before called madrapore this
is a small country that's located near
singapore
it's kind of a haven for a lot of
criminals in the marvel world
the very very super wealthy and the very
very poor who are running you know
brothels drug dens clubs those kind of
havens of scum and villainy but what's
cool about madrapor is it has a lot of
connections with the x-men in the marvel
comics
it also is connected to the hand
actually underneath madrapore is a giant
sleeping dragon that the
hand resurrects at some point so this
show could be used to tie in both the
x-men and potentially daredevil in that
whole side of the marvel universe now
i'm trying to piece together from the
trailer imagery here there's some kind
of sequence with these two
trucks on this european looking highway
but it looks like bucky
and sam are fighting this whole flag
smashers group but zemo is involved with
this plot because later we see him
walking on top of one of those shipping
crates now this club i'm not sure where
it is but there's a lot of cool stuff in
it there's these paintings i think one
of those is a van gogh
and i'm not sure if it's the same club
but there's this big fight scene where
sam and bucky are fighting and there's a
wall of what look like
chimpanzee heads or ape skulls
yeah but i think what we're seeing here
is a trailer that's emphasizing that
kind of love-hate relationship between
these two heroes who are both on either
side of cap both kind of in this
awkward relationship to figure out who
is the worthiest successor of that
shield in fact the editing is
interesting here you see sam discus
tossing the shield and then they sync it
with bucky catching it as if they're
basically just tossing a frisbee back
and forth in the backyard
they kind of hate each other they hate
working with each other but they're both
also soldiers
they've made a ton of sacrifices they've
dealt with a lot and they understand
each other on that level so as the world
is trying to move on
after captain america by making people
like john walker the worthy successor
these two guys are figuring out what
their position is do they want to fight
on the side of the american flag or do
they want to fight on the side of people
like zemo who
want to tear that image down in fact in
this shot in madrid it looks like bucky
and sam are walking behind zemo so are
they going to be fighting them the whole
time
or are they gonna be tempted to join his
side so yeah get ready for this series
it's gonna be really exciting for us to
talk about what we're doing with one
division right now our episodes of
inside marvel our after shows and then
our breakdowns follow the next day we're
gonna do the same thing with the falcon
winter soldier it starts march 19th
there's gonna be six episodes
of it and i'm excited to see how this
series fills out the map
on earth of the marvel cinematic
universe how it answers that question of
what happens to the legacy of captain
america in the mcu
revisits places like sokovia and brings
us to new horizons in places like
madrapore it's gonna be great series
march 19th can't come soon enough
i hope you enjoyed this reaction now i'm
gonna go back in my little hole and
break this down shot by shot because i
feel like there are a ton of really cool
easter eggs that i can't wait to talk
about in the meantime comment down below
with your favorite moment from this
trailer
and the shirt i'm wearing aaron ross is
something that you can get at new
rockstar's official merch store
newrockstarsmerch.com
along with a ton of great designs be
sure to listen to the rockstars on
stereo stereo.com
new rockstars we have live podcasts that
you can interact with us with monday
wednesday and friday the next episode is
coming out
tomorrow morning 8 a.m with our editors
and as always subscribe to new rockstars
hit that notification bell follow me at
ea boss follow new rockstars thank you
for watching and uh
marvel's back i gotta get back to work
[Music]
you